bienvenue dans afrique connecte à free
connect accueil afro tronics l'icône
tchadienne de la musique électro pop
mêlés à des rythmes africains et blues
touareg courtisé notamment par le
producteur de rihanna cartonne à travers
le monde et croule sous les prix
récompensent sacré meilleur dj africains
en 2018 et meilleur artiste électro
africains en 2019 au all africa music
awards caleb rinto by alias afro tronic
s'est révélé au festival afro punk à
paris le célèbre guitariste nous vient
tout droit de l'univers afro futuriste
bonjour affreux tronics et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans l'afrique
connect merci de me recevoir après
treize années comme leader du groupe hk
au ce personnage affreux tronics vous
l'avez créé en 2014 dans un but précis
montrer une autre image du continent
africain une autre image de votre pays
le tchad racontez nous
en fait c'est ça la france trucks est un
concept musical on se retrouve un peu
entre héritiers bâtisseurs hauteur et
j'avais envie de dire autre chose
montrer notre figure de l'afrique qui
n'est pas nécessairement médiatiser les
définitivement s'est essayé de partir
des racines des réformes de chez nous
est
montré que les jeunes africains la
nouvelle génération peut aussi se
projeter dans le futur parce que bon
pour l'histoire nous n'avons pas eu
beaucoup d'influencé cette volonté de la
nouvelle génération a changé le narratif
sur l'africanité qui est un qui résulte
un peu
de ce concept artistique
l'africanité justement c'est un concept
aussi qui revient beaucoup maintenant ça
représente quoi pour vous
pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est sûr que nous avons grandi avec
cette image biaisée de l'africain qui
est dans une posture de recevoir de
l'aide et notre lutte c'est vraiment
que l'afrique soit valorisée pour c'est
qu'elle apporte au reste du monde c'est
un peu la démarche c'est nous voulons
nous voulons des partenaires nous
n'avons plus besoin de gens qui viennent
aider et c'est cette image que la
nouvelle génération de façon globale
africaine veut changer alors afro
tronics vous vous inspirer de l'afro
futuriste un courant artistique
futuriste un univers très visuelle avec
des chorégraphies affreux urbaine que
l'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans ce titre
culte en arabe ou you en duo avec la
chanteuse cédiez know you steam villes
de la région de guerra au tchad extraits
[Musique]
pour
coumba la mode à la main est reda
boudraa
table ce qu'il touche nonagénaire est ce
qu'il peut mais ce que tu m'aides le
coup la marche ont mis tout mon amour à
mériel lama bonne rigueur
[Musique]
ça
ma façon
m
ce sens
oyu c'est vraiment très très visuel
l'afro futurisme c'est un concept
américain au départ avec cette idée de
d'innover dans le traitement des
thématiques afro américaines dans les
domaines culturel technologique mais
aussi le futur sur le continent africain
ce concept il a été repris par bon
nombre d'intellectuels des philosophes
des artistes dont vous faites partie
cela représente quoi pour vous la ferez
au futurisme pour moi c'est une forme
d'émancipation
peut-être le mot est mal choisi mais une
forme d'affirmations
comme je l'avais manche et le tout à
l'heure comme on n'a pas eu une
influence sur l'histoire sur le passé on
s'est dit on peut se permettre
d'imaginer un futur où l'afrique serait
un grand continent et qui
pourrait contribuer de façon efficace
etc et s'asseoir que l'afrique l'afrique
aura une grande voix que nous serons
assis sur les sur la table ou de grandes
décisions sur le devenir du monde seront
prises et c'est le rôle aujourd'hui des
artistes de porter justement ce concept
d'afro futurisme beaucoup de philosophes
l'ont déjà fait aujourd'hui les artistes
doivent prendre ce relais important ou
important parce que déjà je pense que la
culture est un des tangos vecteurs
et je pense que nous avons un outil qui
rassemble plus qu'elle est politique et
donc c'est un message important de dunes
de serpents financement de l'assurance
en soi mais je pense que cette vision de
la future is moule afrique où l'afrique
et est présenté comme important et donc
de devoir passer ses messages à la
nouvelle génération parce que nos pères
c'est un peu un c'est un peu triste si
on regarde l'histoire il manque de
confiance et la nouvelle génération
devrait être plus confiant et c'est un
processus que je pense que l'art
accompagne parce que nous avons cet
outil pour communiquer facilement et il
n'y aura pas je pense qu'il n'y a pas
moins de se développer sans la culture
et donc le connaissant l'importance de
notre rôle dans ce cheminement alors
vous vous revendiquez aussi du
panafricanisme afro futurisme et
panafricanistes c'est le même combat oui
je me sens
le tchadien moins atteints est une
petite partie de ce grand pays que
j'appelle afrique et je pense que pour
qu'on se positionne vraiment dans la
compétition mondiale à tous les niveaux
dans l'économie créancières
sociale culturelle et politique
lorsqu'on a besoin de toutes les forces
de l'afrique donc le panafricanisme est
un élément important dans cette vision a
profité du ces le panafricanisme issus
des indépendances c'est un rêve importés
par beaucoup de deux leaders
d'intellectuels mais aussi un concept un
petit peu vieillissant quand même
considérer même parfois comme une utopie
être panafricaine 2.0 ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui comment est ce que vous
allez dépoussiérer justement le
panafricanisme et portait un message à
la jeunesse africaine moi je pense que
le
sait ce qu'il ya une page qui en train
de se tourner à une génération
relativement plus avertis et décomplexée
qui reprend les choses en main donc en
sachant
que nous nous avons été affaibli parce
qu'il ya eu des divisions donc nous
sommes conscients nous avons voyagé nous
ont fait le tour du monde nous avons
compris que finalement pour mener ce
combat à bout bien il faut se remettre
ensemble donc c'est plus facile
aujourd'hui de de communiquer avec un un
frère de l'afrique du sud 2 du ghana du
sénégal que le groupe avait auparavant
il n'avait pas cette possibilité
aujourd'hui c'est plus facile nous
parlant plusieurs langues à 7 ans
moralité de l'engager donc oui
aujourd'hui de cette vision un peu plus
aptes ou dit désolé pour mon anglais et
du coup j'ai pensé c'est plus facile
pour moi et plus de partir avec cette
génération la décomplexion alors on va
écouter un extrait d'un titre
particulier solal
c'est un titre qui rend hommage
finalement la bravoure de et au
dynamisme de la jeunesse qui reviennent
à travers une histoire l'histoire d'un
amoureuse prête à tout pour retrouver
celle qu'il aime solal partis manifester
[Applaudissements]
les petits monstres à tuer
voilà ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce titre solal c'est un hymne pour
encourager la jeunesse canadienne un
hymne à la liberté de manifester
d'expression oui et
vous placer juste un petit mot nous
avons quand même eu une jeunesse même si
le cadre est pas très connu il ne
jeunesse dans ce pays super responsable
parce que dernièrement
avec l'événement qui a eu avec qui a
importé finalement le président s'est
tiré s'est montrée forte et stable parce
que moi j'étais là au pays quand c'est
arrivé j'avais vraiment peur que le pays
tombe dans le cas où on allait du
président de gas year idriss deby qui a
été assassiné au front et j'ai créé
vraiment que le pays si comme dans le
chaos mais il ya la gérer ça fait
vraiment preuve d'une retenue et parce
qu'elle sait la responsable que nous
avons que si ça éclate au tchad mais ça
arrive à la sécurité de la sous région
et
donc de l'afrique nous nous amusions
beaucoup à garder la sécurité nous avons
beaucoup investi à la lutte contre boko
haram parce que nous savons l'importance
que le tchad est resté stable et donc je
profite de l'écran pour saluer et à
chaque fois que j'ai l'occasion mais j'y
chante la force de cette jeunesse que
certainement même le continent qu'on est
pas assez même et le monde c'est vrai
que le chat d'un pays que l'on ne
connaît pas beaucoup
trop connu peut-être pour ses clichés
l'insécurité la pauvreté l'atmosphère
politique tendu qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de montrer de ce pays de sa
culture de son identité
moi je veux montrer toute la beauté qui
a et toute la force qui a dans nos
cultures nous sommes vraiment j'aime
vraiment le dire en rigolant le meur
dollar fait que nous avons la culture
orientale africaine par le nord et la
culture bantou par le sud et nous sommes
arrivés quand même à garder tout son
équilibre et à vivre à échanger ensemble
et malheureusement ce qui sort du pays
j'ai le temps que les médias
s'intéressent plus quand il s'agit de la
guerre il n'y a pas que la guerre au
tchad il y a une grande joie de vivre il
ya une culture il ya de la bonne cuisine
et il ya il y a une il ya une vie
paisible donc à travers ma musique je
veux inviter les gens à venir découvrir
ce beau pays vous avez la chance d'être
là vous avez vu toute la beauté qui a au
nord du pays et autant au sud et je
pense que c'est important de montrer
autre chose à la maison même si ça va
pas il y à cette beauté c'est à nous de
faire la promotion de cette beauté vous
parlais tout à l'heure de cette jeunesse
qui s'est mobilisée dans la rue john s
vous dit responsable mais il ya quand
même avec les événements récents
maintenant la mise en place d'un conseil
militaire de transition qui est contesté
c'est toujours le cas en face de ces
manifestations gars de la répression
finalement comment cette société civile
tchadienne cette jeunesse tchadienne
peuvent s'en sortir
j'ai confiance j'ai vraiment fois à la
population elle a surtout à la jeunesse
que je à travers le projet pop et aeg
sujet si on est un peu les régions pour
pour en parler j'ai découvert une
vigilance attentive et qui décomplexé
donc ne suis pas pour poursuivre donc
ils sont conscients que chaque geste
chaque action un peu impacté le devenir
les devants du pays c'est sûr que c'est
pas évident nous sortons quand même
d'une génération de plaids il ya eu
tellement de rébellion il y avait
tellement de guerre
notre histoire aux l'assument mais j'ai
quand même espoir j'ai l'espoir avec
toutes les luttes et j'encourage de tout
confiant pour l'avenir politique de
votre pays absolument et toutes ses
formes de d'activisme de résistance qui
a et même
ce gouvernement de transition qui à mon
avis et c'est de faire ce qu'il peut
j'ai confiance et je pense que d'ici la
fin d'année on trouvera convention on a
deux voilà quelque chose d'affreux
tronics on va marquer une courte pause
et se retrouver dans un instant dans
l'afrique connect rester avec nous sur
rt france
bienvenue dans afrique honnête nous
sommes avec afro tronics l'icône
tchadienne de la musique électro pop
l'icône de l'afro futurisme afro tronics
je sais que vous êtes sensibles au sort
du lac tchad de ces populations le lac
le bassin du lac tchad qui fait face
depuis de nombreuses années à une grave
crise humanitaire presque dans
l'indifférence totale terrorisme avec
l'activisme de boko haram sécheresse
déplacement des populations les
explications de krasnaya le lac tchad
dans le centre nord de l'afrique une
zone peu profondes qui s'étend sur 960
mille kilomètres carrés et joue un rôle
vital pour plus de 30 millions
d'habitants dans quatre pays riverains
le tchad le nigeria le niger et le
cameroun les populations aux abords du
lac tchad vivent majoritairement
d'agriculture de pêche d'élevage et de
commerce mais ces dernières années de
nombreux conflits entre éleveurs et
fermiers qui se disputent l'eau et les
pâturages secoue la région crise
sécuritaire mais aussi environnemental
depuis les années 60 le lac tchad se
tarit ayant perdu 90 % de son volume en
50 ans
un fléau qui oblige les populations à
migrer pour trouver de l'eau à ces
problèmes vient s'ajouter une insécurité
grandissante liée à l'installation de
différents groupes terroristes qui
sévissent dans la région comme boko
haram a paru dans le nord-est du nigeria
en 2009 et qui cherche à prendre le
contrôle des îles du lac tchad des
affrontements réguliers qu'ils font au
passage des victimes parmi la population
civile
malgré les efforts conjoints des états
concernés pour protéger la zone la tâche
est ardue
en avril dernier la tacc armée qui
aurait causé la mort de l'ancien
président idriss deby itno illustre la
nature transfrontalière des conflits la
force g 5 c'est la force multinationale
mixte contre boko haram poursuivre leurs
efforts dans le bassin du lac tchad mais
à ce jour la crise sécuritaire ne
s'apaise pas selon le bureau pour la
coordination des affaires humanitaires
de l'onu en 2018 la crise dans le bassin
du lac tchad aurait affecté plus de 10 7
millions de victimes et fait plus de 2.5
millions de déplacés
alors vous êtes engagé afro tronic en
faveur de la paix au sahel on va parler
du lac tchad est plongée dans une grave
crise humanitaire presque dans
l'indifférence totale
c'est votre sentiment également oui
nous avons donc construit de la main un
projet qui s'appelle john player
avec le danseur taïg et qui a un autre
saladier
pour aller rencontrer justement s'est
déplacé là autour du lac et déjà leur
informer que c'est pas dieu qui décide
de ce qui se passe c'est pas ils
subissent des décisions auxquelles il
n'a pas été convié à plusieurs niveaux
de décision politique et est que
justement le
journal planétaire mais aussi ses
d'autres décisions économiques et qui
sont tant de subir donc non une taignons
alors informé est aussi
utilisé l'art pour informer le pen
international parce que c'est sûr que ça
reste comme 17 ans c'est une partie du
monde oublié dans le terre perdue et
c'est dur j'ai le même sentiment
j'essaie de d'en parler citées
dernièrement au mexique
c'est d'initier peut-être des rencontres
pour
amener les gens à j'étais né regarder ce
qui se passe là-bas 11 millions
d'habitants qui dépendent des ressources
du lac tchad vous vous rendez là-bas
assez souvent on imagine comment les
populations ressentent justement cet
oubli
et cette crise humanitaire qu'ils
subissent qu'elle subit il ya des choses
quand même assez assez dramatique est
derrière moi j'étais choqué
ce nous étions dans un village où il y
avait comme seize nationalités ils
s'arrangent à vivre ensemble et dans
dans les choses qui sortaient y avait
des dames qui disait nous avons
l'impression d'appartenir à aucun pays
nous avons vraiment le sentiment de
d'être laissés à nous mêmes et on
s'organise et il était tellement touchée
que nous on est fait le déplacement que
nous étions à venir voir il faudrait que
le monde fasse attention il y à un
gramme un drame naturel qui sévit là bas
en dehors de
dégâts naturelles dues à la sécheresse
où il peut pas nourrir les bêtes qui
sont obligés de se déplacer pour aller
aller vers des endroits où il ya un peu
plus de pâturages il y a encore cette
pression avec boko haram qui encore dû
au fait que il ya le chaos en libye
il faudrait que le monde il fasse
attention et que les responsables
puissent payer les taxes
ces populations n'ont pas à subir et à
payer tout seul parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été combien ces décisions et subissent
et il faudrait que le monde fasse
attention alors vous êtes aussi
évidemment engagé en faveur de la paix
au sahel et vous avez mené une série de
concerts à travers votre pays le tchad à
regarder
aussi loin qu'ils font
[Applaudissements]
c'est nous
c'est pour la corse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
un gros succès donc pour cette série de
concerts au tchad en faveur de la paix
hausse est un projet qui vous tient à
coeur vous avez réussi votre mission
vous avez l'impression d'avoir réussi
cette mission de sensibiliser les
populations oui vraiment j'ai encore le
moyen le dit moi je suis je suis ému de
la façon que la jeunesse a répondu nous
avons
sept un peuple avec un grand coeur et
nous avons tellement plus de choses qui
nous unissent qui nous divise et moi
j'avais envie avec avec ça de leur
rappeler toute la force et la
responsabilité qu'ils ont et
nous avons vu avec les images
aujourd'hui que oui les politiques
prennent justement ses points faibles
pour montrer nos différences mais il ya
tellement les choses que l'usiné c on
l'a montré que c'est possible
des choses comme ça se réalise c'est une
première au tchad parlez nous de ce
projet justement une caravane ans
ponctuée de concerts à djamena la
capitale du tchad mais à l'intérieur du
pays aussi exact donc on a commencé par
deux spectacles lendemain à la capitale
c'est une première et nous étions le
faire dans quatre autres villes qu'à
trois autres villes mondes au combat et
abéché au nord et ses des régions qui
n'ont jamais eu ce genre d'événement
c'est une première et j'ai l'intention
de convaincre de partir en décembre et
l'idée c'est vraiment
envoyer un message clair à boko haram et
au tourisme que nous n'avons pas peur
que nous sommes près que la vie continue
au tchad
et disparaître ce qui se dit et en
dehors et c'est partir avec cette pensée
dans les autres pays du sahel et nous
nous en faisions faire ça à partir de
mars alors vous avez performer aussi
lors du concert d'inauguration du sommet
afrique-france d'ailleurs vous en avez
parlé de votre projet c'est l'occasion
pour vous de promouvoir ce projet paix
au sahel vous avez fait sensation et
puis l'un de vos messages ce jour là
devant le président emmanuel macron
n'est pas passé inaperçu on regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
[Musique]
alors ce jour ce jour là vous avez
vraiment fait vibrer toute la salle et
compris le président emmanuel macron
vous avez eu ces mots nous sommes tous
migrants pourquoi c'était important de
faire passer ce message ce jour là
je voudrais que que le monde ne nous
voit pas comme des étrangers et qu'ils
considèrent danse est justement cette
vision futuriste inclusif que le
continent africain nous appartient à
tous et aussi quand je voyage un peu je
voulais en amérique du nord de dire aux
gens ce certains shows que tu crèves et
ça amène les gens à réfléchir
et à chercher leur origine
donc oui nous sommes à la base tous
africains et c'est pour ça que l'afrique
a tendance à dire frères soeurs parce
que c'est dans nos gènes science que
nous on sait que vous allez tous vous
êtes tous partie de ce continent et
finalement cette terre nous appartient à
tous et 10 de reconnecter avec la
trivialité que nous sommes tous partie
du continent frais que les gens auraient
à notre égard et que travailler pour
résoudre les problèmes du continent ce
travail pour résoudre le problème de
tout le monde savait que cette la
politique migratoire française notamment
les critiqué par beaucoup
qui considère cette politique comme une
continuité notamment de la françafrique
ce que c'est toujours une réalité selon
vous la françafrique moi je pense
qu'entre g j'étudie d'un vignoble avec
beaucoup de retenue et j'étais méfiant
pas à ce sommet et finalement je vous
avoue que je suis agréablement surpris
de la qualité de l'échangé qui a eu la
franchise qui a eu je pense que c'est ce
que nous avons toujours cherché c'est le
dialogue et dire au monde notre point de
vue et nous avons eu le micro donc je
reste confiant que il faudrait il en
faudrait d'autres cette conversion
devrait continuer
même si il y en a qui soupçonne le veut
dans le complot on pense qu'il ya des
stratégies derrière mais il y a quand
même y croquer les soirées bhl et les
africains qui étaient la suisse où ont
été brillants ils ont exprimé les choses
crues j'ai mon truc c'est le début de
quelque chose
les grandes villes restent optimistes
vous avez échangé que le président c'est
votre projet p au sahel ess clora vous
avez obtenu vous des garanties de
collaboration comment il a réagi
il a été très attentif
quoique je reste très méfiant comme
quand tu parles aux politiciens mais
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une ouverture
parce que ce que ce que j'ai trouvé
important mentionné c'est qu'il devrait
considérer et privilégier la voie des
autres acteurs dans dance est dans ce
processus et qui est notamment et à
l'avoir culturel et je vais encore et
souligné qu'il pourrait pas avoir de
développement sans la culture que
j'avais envie qu'il entendait y lit la
perche y est nous avons d'autres
promesses et d'une autre rencontre qui
va se faire donc je pense que il
pourrait il ya un avenir à cette
conversation afro tronic vous emporter
le tchad à l'international vous vivez
d'ailleurs à montréal et vous fait
évidemment le tour du monde on va
regarder un extrait de vos concerts à
l'international
[Musique]
à
de monnaie de bouger les sens vous le
verrez
[Musique]
chronique vous allez repartir en concert
vous l'avais dit au tchad en décembre et
puis un album aussi qui est prévu pour
janvier
j'ai hâte au prochain album et une
tournée qui va certainement commencer au
tchad est un peu partout en afrique
et une autre tournée mondiale qui se
prête le prochaine album qui arrive en
effet ouais mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter à l'affreux tronics
souhaité qu'ils aient davantage
d'ouverture parce que mon ambition de
par l'afrique aux africains c'est
d'apporter la musique africaine dans sur
des chaînes qu'elle a qu'à l'apport
forcément accès donc ce témoin de l
amener encore plus loin un peu partout
dans le monde
merci en tout cas affreux tronics de
cette visite en afrique hohneck merci
beaucoup merci de vous recevoir comment
est retrouvé à free connecte sur nos
réseaux sociaux et en replay sur notre
site arte france point tv merci à toutes
les équipes du mag et techniques pour à
cette émission merci de votre attention
à très bientôt dans un cri connecte sur
rt france
[Musique]